hardest pieced master is the night the  night has a very difficult movement to  understand here we have a night on g1 it  moves like the letter L 1 square up and  to over a once pair to the left and two  squares up or one square to the right  and two squares up this night on g1 can  go to either the H 3 square the F 3  squared or the e2 square let us make a  few moves with the night to be sure we  understand where the night can move if  we bring the night from g1 to f3 and  we'll move the black king for a moment  the knight moves from f3 to e5 the  knight actually controls 8 squares in  this position the knight on e5 can  actually check the black King from 2  squares